hello everyone I'm Tanya lard I'm a
developer advocate at Microsoft and I'm
gonna be presenting protocol DevOps for
a divisive data scientist you can find
me on Twitter if you use Twitter
underrated hashtags check I'm sorry to
handle a check and there is where you
can find all of my slides in case you
want to download them now to follow if
you need to have some text or later on
and then we're going to start with what
I'm actually going to cover in two
slides first I'm gonna do a very brief
introduction to one is DevOps for data
science or envelopes and why all the
data scientists should care about them
I also going to dive into who should be
responsible for implementing ml ops into
our workflows and I will give you some
practical steps for you to get sorry to
it this is not going to be a deeply
technical talk or going very deeply into
a technical or deployment aspects of
machine learning models but will give
practical recommendations on how to
start building from where you are
currently to start adopting some of the
practices and a tiny bit about me I love
pie thin is Python pretty much every day
and I'm also a goal developer expert for
a tensor flow and all machine learning
stuff and I also love mechanical
keywords so if anyone here loves like
ethical keywords I can see my friends
there and come talk to me so just -
sorry did a bit of background if you're
not a machine learning person or a data
scientist at all then probably to are
used to this paradigm in software
engineering where you have your
algorithm and read data as an input and
you have oh sorry then you have
something that processes that and then
in the end you have your answers and you
have normally well-defined answer is
something that you know that you can
start
testing and and and know what you're
expecting in machine learning think
sorry inverted tiny bit or you will have
jury data here and your answer is
normally for example if you are doing
some sort of classification algorithms
you would have those labels in those
answers in the form of labels so if you
want to identify them for example from
different pictures whether what you are
saying is an apple or an orange then you
will have to have a lot of images that
are already tagged for you to identify
that then you put your answers and your
data together and go and pass that
through to create algorithm or a model
depending on what you're actually doing
and eventually you will then use that
newly created algorithm or that newly
created model along with new data or
data that you have not previously seen
to generate new predictions as you would
imagine this creates an additional layer
of complexity because you not always
know what German to get in some cases or
in other cases you might need to have
your algorithm and will accumulate more
data or collect more data over its time
and this will help you to make your
predictions more accurate or more
reliable or faster so you might need to
use that algorithm that you created or
that model that you created and retrain
at or near data to then give better
predictions so how do we actually get
into here normally if your data centers
are work as a data centers you will
start by doing some research and
development and this is a very iterative
fast development processes worry
development process for l0 try probably
different approaches or different models
to get to something that you can
actually then process as something
consumable once you have identified the
best approach or the best model or
algorithm that you want to create the
you want to use then you have to think
about taking that from the research and
development stage until something that
can be production ready that can be
consumed by your users and here's where
normally data scientists started working
a bit closer with the software engineer
is to bring that into production but
what happens then how do we actually
make sure that that model is ready that
my customers can go for example and
upload during Apple versus orange images
and get a prediction or in other cases
how our doctor is using models to
predict or aes image to predict whether
it is breast cancer or colon cancer or
brain cancer and it's usually this part
of the process that this part of the
process that seems to be a bit magical
in some scenarios how do I actually take
that research and development model into
production ready and very so often we
see this kind of scenarios who are
someone developed a novel algorithm or a
very useful model and it's been sitting
some worry for six months 11 months for
it to be taken into production and this
is because usually data science or a
data scientist teams tend to hit this
wall on fire that is once you have
repaired your data build your models and
train it produce some evolutions and a
lot of testing how do I actually ship it
and the thing is because all of this
pipeline or all of this model generation
pipeline is very territorial or a lot of
failure is in the intermediate processes
so when I'm doing my data preparation I
have to first make sure that I know
where my data lives I need to know that
I can track it and I also need to
overcome some storage bottlenecks when I
am doing that iterative processes of
trying different algorithms and training
my models I also have to overcome
sometimes it's lonely it slow processes
to do this and that will depend a lot on
the kind of computer you're using also
sometimes it can be very very hard to
explore in a hyper parameter space it is
if you're in familiar with machine
learning the hyper parameters cannot be
deduced our priori but are you will have
to do some long inter extensive search
for you to actually determine which are
the best hyper parameters I will give
the best optimization on your models and
then if you have very compute intensive
applications you also want to distribute
the loads or distribute a computer but
actually managing this distributed
clusters can be very very hard so you
need help from somebody else and when
we're finally ready to put this into
production and serve we encountering the
common problem self it worked in my
machine but now it doesn't work in
production or it's not scalable enough
what happens when I have only one person
trying to access my resource versus
having 100 or 1000 people trying to
access that resource at the same time so
when we think about how we can overcome
all of these bottlenecks I want you to
think about what your wish would be and
think big how would you normally
overcome it for me it would as a data
sorry machine learner what I would want
is for me to spend more time focusing on
the R&D production izing my code and not
having to worry about that wall on fire
that is taking it from R&D into
production and here is where Emma labs
and robust pipelines actually come into
place because this gives us streamline
secure deployments and this obstructs
this takes abstraction from all of that
magic that I showed in the previous
slides these designs proper
responsibilities and proper automation
tasks for taking this models into
production so ok who should be
responsible for the actual automation
and for the actual deployment that's a
question that people often ask the
problem is that in many companies we see
that data scientists and data engineer
is overlap quite a lot and we think that
we sure certain responsibilities that
that paradin metal in depend on and
software engineers are seem to be
perceived or are perceived very very far
having very different set of skills so
they're very very involved in a
conversation or involved in the process
very late and the truth is when we think
about skills it is not just not Venn
diagram and overlapping part between
data scientists and data engineers but
actually um it's a convergence of skills
worry data scientists are really really
good at doing all the machine learning
AI deep learning advanced analytics and
statistics and data engineers are very
good at pipeline state integrity
validation and under readiness or it is
skilled better Ament of each one
overlaps as in a gradient but we still
have that part in the middle that part
in the middle that is under 7 reserved
that is hunter looked
and this is where the role of a machine
learning engineer or someone that takes
care of the operations productions and
optimization comes into place and here's
where we have all of these ability to
integrate DevOps Centauri machine
learning pipelines conceive UPS is
actually the intersection of these roles
and the processes and products so we can
deliver better value to other customers
to our accompany to our teammates and
truly it is a tree community a true team
effort and by adopting these practices
entire machine learning operations or
our machine learning workflows we are
trying to reduce all of these end-to-end
cycle times and eliminate as many
frictions as we want as we can so I hear
you that all of you say I don't work in
a wig company wait a lot of machine
learning engineers
I don't worry in a big company where we
have this very distinct roles when I
work in a place where everyone is pretty
much responsible for everything and I am
a data scientist by day and evenings I'm
trying to ship my products and I do a
lot of stuff the beauty of open stories
under beauty of having things in the
cloud is that you can start building
jerry machine law reading jobs or at
your Emma lobs platform with what you're
already using you don't need to start
integrating new tools so you can start
if you have your a code on github or you
get love or a big bucket that's fine
that's a good start
then if you're using things like your
flow or machine learning services or in
machine learning workspaces and ensuring
that also works and then you can
integrate dive way of Ashura DevOps or
Jenkins for circle CI or again have
actions to give you the capabilities of
continuous integration and continuous
delivery so that way you can bring all
of the beauty of
Revathi design Seiko system and machine
learning ecosystem to build robust
pipelines to build robust analog
platforms and this platform should take
care of your environment of your
development of your testing training and
Retraining of your models deployment and
all monitoring and alerting and you can
put your ISA tag together with all of
the tools that you're using the previous
talk integrated it was about our flow
for beginners so you can also have
things like air flow and Luigi or a cue
flow tareka straighter pipelines or a
schedule tasks so that way you can have
these three distinct roles of jory data
scientist or a developer or yourself or
engineer and someone working in
operations all working together towards
the same goals using the tools that I
normally use to develop during job or it
to do their workflows and get a
reproducible automatable stack so you as
a data scientist you can still use
Jupiter in Novak's version control our
machine learning services and assure
pipelines to do to integrate reserved up
model management enter software engineer
friend or your colleague can use their
favorite tools whether it's vs code or a
PI term or anything else again use
version control build pipelines for
continuous integration and build docker
containers and then the abrasion person
will take that pipeline that was created
before it to take into production for
example using communities so how do I go
or how do you go from what you have now
to dis automatable
ml ops platform
first sorry to my having everything in
version control in source control a lot
of the day designs scientist use Jupiter
Novak's so if you already have to
Jupiter no boots in source control
that's a good step even better if you
have everything all your code other
comments
sanitizer Jupiter no bigs when to put it
when to push to get help make sure that
outputs are not there every single part
of your pipeline also to infrastructure
and dependencies try to have three
infrastructure is a code and that means
covering your environments and maybe a
subset of your data if you're providing
additional data for your folks or your
colleagues to reproduce a minimal
working example make sure the data is
there except your training data
Jerry training data get a version
control or get is not intended to work
for a person in controlling of large
data sets and also keep in mind that all
your training data the raw data should
be unknown shared data source that
everyone in your team could access and
very important
jerrod data should not be changed it
should be immutable didn't touch it
not with sick with nothing your raw data
is is there for a reason the second step
that you can start introducing is having
deterministic environments how often do
you pull a dipper notebook or a script
from one of your colleagues or even a
notebook that you run six months ago and
you end up with things like this like
import a package and a package doesn't
exist or something has changed over it
or using an outdated version that has
significant API changes and all of your
results are changed whenever environment
you're using whether it's the cloud or a
URI developing on a Jupiter hog that is
self hosted itself maintained or you are
developing locally with
your editor of choice make sure that
your environment is as deterministic as
possible because your laptop is not a
production environment so you need to
pull it proof yourself or participate
for example is fund environments because
it gives me a lot of flexibility for me
to be able to try different versions of
packages use different Python
environments but then when I want to
take things into production I normally
have to convert that into a docker
container because that works on my
machine on a virtual machine and on
curing it is sometimes maintaining both
a condom vironment and docker container
is can be very very problematic and
that's where libraries like reporter
Dockery also helps you to abstract that
so if you already have direct code into
github and your environment in the form
of an environment a demo file or a
requirement subtext or things of the
such you can use that to generate
version control repo docker images and
docker files so when again when Cheree
trying to define your environments make
sure that you specify the versions as
much as possible especially those that
are critical for the operation of your
models the next step is using pipelines
for repeatability and reproducibility
it's very very hard when you have 1,000
Python script to identify what tasks are
being run in which order if you have
very set a very well-defined set of
steps and tasks that should be run in a
specific order it's easier for you to
trace back and stop any tasks that need
to be done again Ori need to be modified
so impossible tracheas things like cute
flow or flow lychee Azure machine
learning pipelines where you can have as
a step one for example your data
preparation step two trick training step
3 model registration and so on and so
forth I mean most of all most of these
options or most of these tools have a
visual interface that also allows you to
track every single run for example here
you can see that I'd have a pre person
step a training and registering and it
also tells you when it was done
generation and whether they are suitable
already set up for rias so this gives
you a very very good overview of all the
tasks that you're running and all of
your pipelines so doesn't matter how
complex your task is in that case I had
preparation training and registering but
you can also integrate other tasks like
creating docker image there integer it
gonna use and use a docker image to
attach it to your computer and run that
pipeline but if you have all of this
designed or defined as code dream for
structuring to find this code and in
version control it's much easier to keep
track of how this tasks and despite
lines evolve over time and the next step
is automate wisely automation can do
wonders for you and your workflows what
you also have to have a very critical
eye about what you're gonna ultimately
[Music]
we kind of spend a lot of time trying to
automate a task that takes us five
minutes and we only do once every year
and then you have to think whether that
automation is actually worth it if you
in turn are performing a scheduled task
every week that actually takes you three
hours or half a day or a full day then
probably that's a task that you could be
automating
something that you could definitely opt
mate automate is orchestration and
continue slavery all off of all of your
machine learning products if you start
integrating I sure it evolves or Godot
actions or drinking's or circle CI into
your workflows it also allows you to
detect errors and box earlier way before
they reach production stage and you can
also integrate with many other services
and you can start having smart alerting
when your model is not performing the
way it should be
or when a merge request is introducing
breaking changes into your code bases
and you can also set it so that it
trigger is on code events like branching
merge requests or pull requests and also
non cutting events so imagine that you
have a model and you want to update your
dependencies every three months or every
six months you can set automated tasks
the world upgrade your dependencies test
your code base order model against this
new dependencies and report and only
update them if they pass the tests and
you can have your continuous integration
and your full machine learning pipeline
starting from those initial steps that I
showed before that is preparation
training registration integrate
continuous integration to do your
containerization and jury deployment to
Kira Nerys or wherever is that you're
having enjoy deployments in and
everything starts becoming much more
traceable so you can start tracing again
your pipelines every single step is code
every single step is version control
traceable and you can analyze every
single triggers every single trade all
that are it that are executed under a
code sorry
from again training to verifying to
deploy so in this case this model is
being tested first creating the
container and then all the way onto
deployment and testing my infrastructure
once my model has been deployed so in
brief what can I store it or what can
you start doing to go from where you are
ante up to automatable fully robust
pipelines start doing source control
right create deterministic environments
and however this are defined make sure
that they are deterministic start using
pipelines for repeatable workflows and
start adopting continuous integration
and continuous delivery as part of your
deployments if you want to learn more
about any of the resources that I put in
here
Theresa Lane there are two links and you
can download download older slides and
just before I finish also come talk to
us at the Microsoft booth we're more
than happy to help you with your
deployments if you want to integrate
actually DevOps or amai ml and we're
also running a creeper face competition
so oh and that's it thank you
[Applause]
right thank you for being right on time
so up to a second and unique you know
the drill by now just raise your hand if
you have a question we have five minutes
so maybe just for five questions no way
back I see anybody closer hi thanks for
the for the nice talk I do have a
question about inside the team and my
experience would be that if you have 10
engineers attended a scientist it'll
likely be 10 different ways of doing the
work would you advocate trying to
standardize that a single tool for your
pipe has a single - a for continuous
deployment or would you or how have you
guys approached it so in previous themes
that I've been where what has worried
best is standardizing as much as
possible because listen to the team
prefer using github and another one
prefer is using good lab and somebody
else is a the use of shuri develops
somebody else prefers Travis or circle
CI it starts becoming very very
complicated if someone from another team
needs to take over a project it there is
a lot of there are a lot of tools and a
lot of things to maintain and duplicate
code bases everywhere so we try to
standardize as much as possible start
with something that could be replicated
or easily maintained by all the teams or
by everyone that should be responsible
and then move from Terry obviously
you'll have specifics per project or a
specifics three different things but I
would try to standardize as much as
possible
very well next question
don't I see a hand or deserting them Oh
sir Hey so my team has been sort of
hesitant to actually end up using
notebooks due to the sort of issues when
notebook changed a lot in version
control and I figured can you dig a bit
deeper in how you handle those are there
tools or practices that help you
essentially prevent to get your pasta
from being loaded well I have other
resources on that topic
precisely Jupiter Novak's are amazing
for our tree like dissemination is fine
our class titration sorry excellent but
there he don't play nicely with version
control and unless you have very good
practices it can be very very
problematic from for production
readiness and so what I normally suggest
is when you need something that needs to
be into production to have actual Python
scripts or modules if you're going to be
reusing heavily reusing parts of the
code you'll have to go back to creating
a Python package or a Python module that
will give you that flexibility and place
nicer avoid production ready systems and
if you are planning to use for example
no bigs to create parameterized reports
in conjunction with Luigi or airflow
during mating but again you have to be
very very careful that every time George
making an LP into version control very
sanitized meaning that all of the output
are cleared under tools that will do
that for you and I can't remember
married to name out of my the top of my
head but I can provide the links to
other resources or my other sites that
have a lot of best practices when
working with milk bags and and tools to
integrate them into workflow but I would
not recommend
having your production ready things
ordering productionize models in Novak's
where well my films has 12:55 and with
that we have to release the room and go
grab lunch have a break
we remember the round of applause for